it don't even taste like anything it's
water it's water he said this stuff
the that's what I mean he hasn't drank a
bottle of water clear in this it don't
taste like anything but it's good for
your body your kidneys bro you got to
give your kidneys a bath brother what
are you going to do do you really want
to do this take them all out take all
those
di right there look man get them all out
where the D Co at where he's high he's
stashing the coke oh my gosh look at
this
[Music]
man let me get one of those too get one
too man get one oh man Diet Coke for
everybody yeah oh man
slice he wa hey hey uh Shaq got any Diet
Coke over there here you go Ary thanks
man man appreciate that got some ice put
some ice on that thing my last one put y
don't y'all feel my
pain